recall that you can click on the
timestamp in the description to skip
this longish introduction
salvador pius is an aerospace engineer
formerly working at the naval air
station and currently working at the
united states air force his patents and
papers have attracted international
attention for their potential military
and energy production applications if
true and feasible then they could change
the way that we travel communicate as
well as see ourselves in the cosmos this
is an exclusive interview and the first
time salvator pius has ever come on
camera this is part one of a two-part
interview so if you have questions for
sal for next time then leave them below
click on the time stamp in the
description if you'd like to skip this
intro my name is kurt jaimungle i'm a
torontonian filmmaker with a background
in mathematical physics interested in
explicating the variegated terrain of
theories of everything from mainly a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as understanding the role
consciousness has to fundamental reality
the plan is for this podcast sometime
this year to lead somewhere perhaps even
earlier starting with ideas and gauge
theory which begin in ideas and lead
group theory and build up to the
infinite categorical approaches to
physics like infinite categories and
modal homotopy type theories as well and
even geometric algebra the reason being
that the physical theories of everything
and the language to understand them and
the unification attempts are more
elegantly written and understood from
those perspectives at least to some
people outside of the universities there
are no accessible texts on this
let alone media content so hopefully the
toe podcast will serve as a stanchion
supporting the quest for understanding
the mathematical fundamental principles
if you enjoy witnessing and engaging
with others in real time on the topics
of consciousness psychology physics and
mathematics then check out the
description for a link to the discord
and subreddit there's also a link to the
patreon which is patreon.com
kurtjmungle if you'd like to support
this podcast as support from the patrons
and the sponsors are the only reasons
that i can bring podcasts of this
quality and depth as this is now what
i'm able to do full time thanks to your
support speaking of sponsors there are
three the first sponsor is brilliant
during the winter break i decided to
brush up on some of the fundamentals of
physics particularly with regard to
information theory as i'd like to
interview chiara marletto on constructor
theory which is heavily based in
information theory now information
theory is predicated on entropy at least
there's a fundamental formula for
entropy so i ended up taking the
brilliant course i challenged myself to
do one lesson per day and i took the
course's random variable distributions
and knowledge slash uncertainty what i
loved is that despite knowing the
formula for entropy which is essentially
hammered into you as an undergraduate it
seems like it comes down from the sky
arbitrarily and with brilliance for the
first time i was able to see how the
formula for entropy which you're seeing
right now is actually extremely natural
and it'd be strange to define it in any
other manner there are plenty of courses
and you can even learn group theory
which is what's being referenced when
you hear that the standard model is
predicated on u1 cross su-2 cross su-3
those are league groups continuously
groups visit brilliant.org slash tow
t-o-e to get 20 off an annual
subscription and i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons i think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you can now comprehend subjects
you previously had a difficult time
grocking the second sponsor is ground
news if you're someone like myself who's
ever exposed to the unrelenting
onslaught of digital media you've become
increasingly skeptical of the veracity
of the information you're receiving
particularly with regard to balance and
that's where ground news comes in for
every breaking news story they'll show
you which media outlets are reporting on
the issue and where they fall on the
political spectrum you can instantly
spot media bias discover stories outside
your own perhaps unrecognized echo
chamber and attain some clarity
especially in these chaotic times the
ground used website and app lets you
compare headlines from left center and
right sources simply with a swipe and
their blind spot feed will show you
stories that are not being reported by
one side of the political spectrum
subscribers also gain access to features
like mynews bias which lets you track
your reading habits so you can see how
factual your sources are who owns them
and much more ground news isn't better
news it's an improved manner of the
consumption of news download the ground
news app or browser extension to make
sure that you're seeing the full picture
visit
www.ground.news slash toe to demand more
from your news the third sponsor is algo
now algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce return and
inventory write downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by amjad
hussein who's been a huge supporter of
this podcast since near its inception in
fact amjad has his own podcast on ai and
consciousness and business growth and if
you'd like to support the tow podcast
then visit the link in the description
to see amjad's podcast because
subscribing to him or at least visiting
supports the toe podcast indirectly
thank you and enjoy if you can see this
type in these pretzels are making me
thirsty
these pretzels are making me thirsty
let's see
yes okay so we're live
we are live sal
all right all right
so
salvator pais is that correct did i
pronounce it correct sir wow one of the
few to pronounce it right at the mark
great great so sal firstly no need to
call me sir i'm kurt i'm your friend
and tell the audience about your story
how did you come to these patents how
did you come to these ideas and what are
these ideas
well um
all right it's a long story but
the whole idea started from maxwell's
equations the heavy side version of
maxwell's equations as you well know
maxwell's equations is a series about
that
20 equations with 20 unowns uh written
in quaternion formulism it's uh
they were extremely hard to deal with uh
and don't forget they were actually an
ether theory at the time
um
later einstein did away with the
luminesce ether even though she slightly
reintroduced it in 1921 in a paper that
no one wants to talk about so i won't i
think it's got side lights and
relativity anyway
to make a very long story short
uh i noticed
that a simple dimensional analysis of
the heavy side version of maxwell's
equations a heavy side version of them
they're you know the four equations for
unknowns that every physics student
knows to love
what makes this computer and these
devices that we're using now in our
podcast uh
uh feasible uh you could call them the
laws of classical electromagnetism
uh
and they talk about practically uh
electric field e and uh uh magnetic uh
induction term b
also known as the
the magnetic flux density
and uh
a simple relationship between these two
terms e equals c b
comes out of maxwell's equations where c
is the speed of light
now
i noticed that uh
from
from these equations you could actually
uh get a term for the pointing for the
magnitude of the pointing vector
and uh
it comes if you write the pointing
vector
if you go if you refer to my papers and
you can give the papers in your in your
podcast and your uh
feed so so people know how to refer to
them they're series of papers not just
the patents but right the papers that go
yeah so just so you know sal one of the
reasons i'm super excited to be speaking
with you not only well there are many
reasons but one of them
i've been spending weeks going through
these papers i have quite a few here
and i'll link all of these papers in the
description
and thank you i hope we can get to some
of these notes that i have too
great that'd be absolutely great okay
but to make a very long story short i
noticed that it is possible by doing
this to um
okay the whole idea is uh it leads to
control motion of electrically charged
matter
from solid to plasma states
subjected to
accelerated spin and or accelerated
vibration
via
rapid acceleration transients this gives
rise to high energy electromagnetic
energy fluxes which are commensurate to
high energy densities
hence it is possible in my opinion
to achieve the schwinger limit that is
electromagnetic energy fluxes on the
order of 10 to the 33 watts per meter
square which is commensurate to energy
densities on the order of 10 to the 25
joules per meter cube
so in other words you can lead to
something called a quantum
electrodynamic vacuum breakdown
when you achieve yes so sorry as an
aside for the audience if you're not
following what some of these terms are
don't worry because as we continue
throughout the podcast i'm going to be
stopping sal at different points to
explain certain terms like even simple
terms like what is a piezoelectric
material i know it's piezo however
people want to pronounce it what is the
superconductor what is the cooper pair
what is the stringer limit and so on and
so on so this will serve because this
we're going to have another conversation
this will serve as a prelude to that
conversation correct sir and this is
what i love about your podcast not only
do you have a tremendous ability to
understand
your guest's work and you really take
your time and and
i've never seen anybody
uh
the the work of carl fristen for example
was amazing how you i think you're one
of the few people who understands the
free energy uh
formalism but anyway um
that was tough well other than he that
is uh yeah uh okay i chose it because of
your background in theoretical physics
and mathematics because you are a
truly
knowledgeable of this matter and not
only that but you go in detail
as to the work
of the guest which is amazing compared
to other podcasts i i you know i i chose
you and also you mentioned whether you
know on your rose cold hard interview
you mentioned
if there's any possibility of getting in
touch with me so i said you know
why not just
yeah cut the middle man and yeah and go
directly to you the whole idea is is
this you have tremendous ability from
the point of view of your background in
theoretical physics and mathematics and
this is why
i am on this podcast because i want to
speak to um what i look at as a member
of the mainstream physics community i
need to engage with that
with that community
so as to at least
have them look at this work
without uh
being referred to as a navy ufo or uap
patents and so forth
because there's stigma around that
there is great stigma around that sir
still
and unfortunately even though
certain events uh for example have even
brought to the uh
this you this new uap uh office being uh
founded and so forth i i i will not i
will not
touch on that on you know unless
you go into that particular subject i'll
keep it
relevant to my work
but it is important to realize that this
particular work
could also have other implications
now
why did i call it the the pais effect
a lot of people say that it was great
hubris on my part but after all it is an
original concept and it's so much easier
to say the price effect than to say
control motion of electrically charged
matter from
solids to plasma states
subjected to blah blah blah blah and all
everything that i've said before that
gives rise to these high energy
densities remember with high energy
densities
you can manipulate locally the
space-time fabric what we understand as
as
some
emerge something that emerges from the
quantum vacuum
and hence
the idea of a possible breakdown of this
quantum vacuum at these high energy
densities but okay to go back to your
original question what what prompted me
to actually write the patents was inc it
was incredibly hard to get my ideas peer
reviewed
i i would get rejection and i i tried
some very uh
uh influential and very prestigious
journals and i was
basically rejected within a matter of
days and why do you think that is
i believe
this particular work actually
nobody believes that such a high energy
densities
can be achieved there is no way to
manipulate
the space-time continuum there's no way
to in any way uh engage with the quantum
vacuum
and i believe that by this
uh manner and i will not repeat the
price effect because it after a while it
bothers me too i'll tell you the truth i
i wish someone could come up with a
better
name for it and call it that
and and maybe then they'll use it and
and uh and my ideas won't be construed
as the words of a crackpot and
one of the greatest physicists of all
time i have the greatest respect for
uh doctor finally so
um
okay
so then i went
a different route but this route was
extremely hard because
in the invention disclosure process at
the navy this is quite an arduous
process first of all you have to apply
you have to speak directly to uh the
patent attorney
for navair
in this case it was uh mr mark glute one
of the best navi has
and you have to be good to understand
some of the finer points of my theories
and
then i had to go through a trial by fire
and let's put it that way they're called
the invention evaluation board
and their group of navi fellows
we're talking about phds a lot of them
have phds in the fields from quantum
physics to electrical engineering to
mechanical engineering aerospace
engineering
these are no light weights
and
that room can pack sometimes up to
12
from 12 to 18 people that i beat you
basically they give you 20 to 30 minutes
sometimes less
to explain your work
and whether that are you referring to
this
that is actually no
that is um
actually
that was done for a craft using um yes
it was a
a patent attorney a patent examiner
interview so after
the invention
disclosure was accepted by the invention
evaluation board at pax
you actually
go through and write
your uh what's called a patent
application and that's given to the
uspto the united states patent and
trademark organization that's when
usually a primary examiner when it's
something
that this this elevated physics this
advanced physics usually a primary
examiner uh will examine the work and in
this case mr philip
bonzell
was the primary examiner
he was uh
he was taken aback because there's
he said there's no way you can generate
these high energy densities
so we had to convince them and that's
why that particular um
uh
it's called uh about a patent examiner
interview where you actually
try to argue your case and show
to the patent examiner that it is worth
allowing the patent
and shortly after that
he actually
rejected again
and we had to file a a an appeal based
partially on on that
the patent examiner interview
and he actually allowed
and he wrote very minimal he said see
appeal
that's all he wrote for allowing the
patent once we explain to him some of
the finer points of the work
what were some of those finer points
that convinced him and what were they in
response to so what were his criticisms
he said there's no way that you can get
electric field strengths on the order of
uh 10 to the 18 volts per meter and b
fields so in other words magnetic flux
density terms on the order of 10 to the
nine tesla remember that relationship
that e equals cb that i talked about 10
to the 18th you know your c is on the
order of 10 to the eighth meter per
second
and hence that
um
actually three times ten to the eighth
meters per second but you can say that
on the order of ten to the eighth meter
per second uh yeah the the whole idea
the whole idea is that i was able to to
show to him
in this telephone interview while he had
the slide presentation in front of him
that
it is possible to generate the
electromagnetic energy fluxes on the
order of 10 to the 33 watts per meter
square which speaks to quantum
electrodynamic vacuum breakdown and once
you break the quantum
vacuum you can
basically
manipulate gravitational fields
everything the vacuum
the vacuum is the resident medium is the
domain where all these forces interact
only four known forces interact
and yes uh gravity can be regarded as a
force even though general relativity
shows that it is most
mostly a curvature of space-time
structure
still
we'll talk about the super force later
so
we and and
you must eventually have some uh you
have some tremendous points on quantum
gravity and eventually we have to lead
and do that but let's stick with the
patents for now so once you go through
the invention evaluation board
they they debate for it it can take up
to two two to three weeks
whether
they should proceed
with your invention whether they should
file a patent application
and on five occasions
every five of them so we talk about the
room temperature superconductor we're
talking about the high frequency
gravitation wave generator we're talking
about craft using an inertial mass
reduction device we're talking about
high energy electromagnetic field
generator and we'll talk about the
plasma compression
fusion device which by the way
that is the only
one that i could get in a prestigious
journal namely the um the ieee
transactions on plasma science it's
pretty prestigious and it's not only
well regarded by plasma physicists but
also electrical engineers after all it
is
publication
so um
again that also took some doing two
independent peer reviews it's extremely
hard for people to accept new ideas
that is the bottom line
you asked the question previously as to
why do you think mainstream physics
stays aways from you because
these ideas that the
let's call it the
fine the feynman effect
sure sure okay and the feynman effect
this shows this shows
that it is possible to interact with the
quantum vacuum to generate such high
energies of an electromagnetic nature in
this case as to affect the energy
densities
locally
of the space-time continuum so
great and we're going to get into detail
on that either in this podcast or the
next one because i'm still unclear even
though i've read
quite a bit of your work i'm still
unclear what it means to interact with
the quantum vacuum and pull out energy
but we can talk about that oh
it's not pulling out energy here this is
important to understand what it does it
actually uh
it breaks it apart it creates a
for want of a better word some sort of a
black hole in in in that particular
locality so it actually it it creates a
void within the vacuum within that
region
there is nothing absolutely nothing
we're not talking there is no quantum
vacuum
but
again how you achieve that is with
extreme high energies densities you need
that because if you look carefully a
general relativity
uh look at the formalism that einstein
uses
instead of using the rigid tensile i use
the einstein tensor because it's easier
to explain is g sub mu nu
equal 8 8 pi
times g big g which is the um
um
the universal gravitational uh
constant divided by c to the fourth and
the whole thing so that
scalar constant times your tensor your
energy density t sub mu nu
okay okay and if you look at it uh
dimensionally you realize that that
scalar has in it what i call the super
force
c to the fourth divided by g which is on
the order of 10 to the 44
newtons
and that basically represents the force
of unification of all known forces but
that's for a later time in the podcast
okay
so when you look at that formula you
realize that in order to affect the
space-time curvature in order to affect
um
locally
your spatial temporal geometric
structure let's call it that
um you must have extremely high t sub
union you have very high energy
densities and how do you obtain that
versus this effect that
you know it's the highest
effect oh yeah sure so just for people
who are unclear what we mean when we say
find men effect we're somewhat tongue in
cheeky referring to it as the feminine
effect and we may interchange between
pious effect and feynman effect and pi
salvatore here we'll go into exactly
what the pious effect is
shortly so firstly there's a quote from
ross coltar's book which says are dr
salvatore paeus's mind-blowing patents
merely a pathetic bluff to scare off
america's rivals what is your response
to that
absolutely not sir
they are not
a bluff
a lot of people have called them this
information
a lot of people have called them this
information but if you look closely the
physics is correct
all you have to do is look at it
dimensionally and you'll see that that
electromagnetic energy flux is the not
only the correct dimensions but has the
correct physics in it but you realize
that okay
it is possible to get these kind of
energy densities not by just having very
high voltages
in the local area very high electrical
charges but also for example very high
frequencies of either vibrations or spin
now to go back to your question on james
sheehy because that's important i think
this one that's coming up go ahead sir
you were going to ask about dr james
sheehy yes he attested that it was
operable is that correct
these are the terms that he used and i'm
not quite sure exactly what he meant by
it but
if you look at the physics again these
are based on the laws of
classical electromagnetism these
computers these devices this microphone
i'm using none of them would work if it
wasn't for the veracity the validity of
the heavy side version of
what we understand now is classical
electromagnetics
so yeah
maybe this is what he meant was he able
to test it
none
how should i say
as far as i know there's no such craft
out there that's using the paius effect
that
we try to do what's called the high
energy electromagnetic field generator
at pax river we try to actually do the
experiments we try to accelerate the
charge
uh in spin up to a hundred thousand rpm
so we talk about ten thousand radians
per second
so quite high angular velocities but
uh
the charge that was used was could not
be achieved more than ten to the minus
eight coulombs and you need at least a
one coulomb electrical charge to affect
some of these um more remarkable um
phenomena
okay so let's focus in on this one
coulomb charge so i did some back of the
envelope calculations here and let's say
we have a capacitance of one ferrite
then if we had a sphere it would have to
be larger than the radius of the earth
now let's imagine we had a sphere that
is one meter so fairly large but not
terrible
to place a one coulomb charge on it
it would have to have a potential of
about one gigavolt now that's quite a
significant amount of potential so is
this feasible is this one coulomb charge
reasonable i believe it is
yes i believe it is but it it it cannot
be your regular uh
the truth of the matter is you will
never achieve these kind of energy
densities with solids
but you can achieve them with plasmas
now exactly how that's done
i cannot say on the podcast because that
could represent an issue of national
security and sir i am a patriot
can never give away certain um
things
sure but yeah
it is much better to work with plasmas
than with uh electrically charged solids
so j just leave it at that but it is
feasible it's physically feasible to do
this
as far as i know no one has done it
but
you know
you never know
so where did you get your ideas from
what was the inspiration
the
primary inspiration was how how could
you
this is the
thing that bothered me tremendously is
if you look again at general relativity
this this g sub mu u equals this scalar
constant times uh times your energy
density
it just it bothered me tremendously that
this energy density could not be
achieved and i kept on telling myself
maybe if i go back to the fundamental
equations and not necessarily
maxwell's quaternion formalism but
heavyside's equation maybe there is a
way
to do this not by using high voltages
high charges
by using high frequencies and then it
occurred to me what if i accelerate
either in spin or in vibration because
then you get non-linear terms you get
parabolic terms in your angular
frequency of either spin or vibration
because remember
spin and vibration they have similar
equations
if you look carefully
so what is the difference between spin
and vibration
i think it is much easier to achieve
very high frequencies
of
vibration than
high frequency of spin
because not only
again when you deal with spin you cannot
have for example discs that are hard
that are high in diameter say than
four inches because
the centrifugal forces that would break
this thing apart especially at 100 000
rpm
so but it is in my opinion it's possible
to get frequencies of vibration very
high
uh
even exceeding 10 to the eighth
one divided by second
by uh subjecting it to for example
pulsed current going through these piezo
or piso however you choose to pronounce
let's call them piezoelectric uh
elements
then it it is possible but remember
pulse current because what you need in
it is an accelerated vibration okay so
let's break this down yeah what is a
piazza electric material
a piezoelectric for example uh a pct
it's from lead zerkin a titanate uh it's
it's a composite material the whole idea
is when it's subjected to a voltage it
can actually shows the formation of the
material itself
or if you uh
expose the material to deformation
stresses and so forth it gives rise to
voltages so people have used it one way
or used it the other way i use it from
the point of view if you send the
current through it so an electrical
charge accelerated
through it then you get these very high
frequencies of vibration
this is how i use piezoelectrics yeah
people can understand it with their
phones the fact that you can press and
that your phone registers it is because
there's a piezoelectric material there
or no
sure
why not yes it is quite possible that
the piezoelectrics are used in
many components many devices so yes
absolutely okay in other words just to
reiterate it's
you apply pressure and then there's a
charge
is it a charge or there's a voltage
there's a voltage
that's generated
and and again because you have the
material there's a capacitance uh
charges capacitance times voltage and
and
that's how
charge
gets generated but uh right so okay so
piezo is a relationship between applying
pressure and then an increase in voltage
yes or in this case uh applying a
current through your element your
piezoelectric element and getting
vibration of that
pct element
which is what i use it for so what is
vibration are you talking about
vibration at some atomic level so the
atoms are just jiggling
vibration of the of the composite itself
you can actually see this thing vibrate
once you put a current through it
so i think frequency i if i remember uh
correctly something to do uh it's like
the frequency of vibration is on the
order of 1 divided by square root of lc
where
l is your induction c is your
capacitance of whatever circuit you have
the
that's a common formula for
for it but
this is how you get vibration from these
elements by passing a current through it
and in this case you don't just pass a
constant current you pass a pulse
current ah okay now what is the
difference between those two
because that would elect
accelerate the frequency of vibration
that would make it
that would bring in this non-linearity
in angular frequency of either spin or
vibration that's part of that
remember that i spoke of the magnitude
of the pointing vector being the
electromagnet now is that because it
resonates
yes yes yes
that as well because what's resonance
after all that's an amplification of
energy
okay so is one way to understand this
like there's this famous video of a
bridge that's wobbling and it's because
of the wind and the wind happens to be
at the frequency of the bridge so if we
were to just apply that wind straight
without any oscillations in the wind
then the bridge wouldn't oscillate so
much it's almost like the wind is
pulsing and you're saying something
similar is going on where you pulsate
some piezoelectric material with
electricity at some resonant frequency
and you increase this frequency of
vibration right and you make it on
non-linear it's no longer a leaning
effect so no longer goes as as omega it
goes
as omega square
okay that's part of the uh
if you look carefully at the equations
that i use uh um
to generate this the magnitude of the
pointing vector which is really the high
energy electromagnetic energy flux
uh and remember that that em energy flux
it's really c times your energy and
again c the speed of light times the um
well in this case would be epsilon zero
e square where e is your uh electric
field strength
so uh
your your um electromagnetic energy flux
is really c times
the energy density
so that's how the two are related that's
why i say 10 to the 33 watts per meter
square is commensurate with the 10 to
the 25 joules per meter cube that's an
energy density
and that brings about
uh the
this effect of quantum electrodynamic
vacuum
breakdown that can actually be found in
in a great book it's an ai double a
publication i believe by uh is it mark
millis and and eric w davis dr davis dr
eric davis
known for other things as well um
they actually um i think they they were
the two main editors for this book a
great book called foundations
or frontiers frontiers
of advanced physics
i'm not sure exactly the na the the name
of the book
but yeah uh
uh mark millis and eric w davis they
edited this book uh they say frontiers
of propulsion science thank you sir
that's it and in it they speak of this
this ability to have quantum
electrodynamic vacuum breakdown
based on this idea of getting energy
densities on the order of 10 to the 25
joules per meter cube
if you can do that
and how how do you do that
by using the bias effect or the fireman
effect
that's
however you choose to call it
okay
getting back to this question of
well maybe whether you should call it
the schwinger effect yeah well the
stronger effect is already
right right right so this breakdown of
the quantum vacuum that you keep
referring to is that related to the
swinger effect the creation yes yes
because uh
it it is um schwinger again schwenger
thomannaga and feynman uh received the
nobel prize for quantum electrodynamics
now
schwinger julian schwenger
he came up he basically said if we can
get electric field strengths on the
order of 10 to the 18 volts per meter
which is
uh which would mean
magnetic induction b fields on the order
of 10 to the nine tesla
then we could actually
get quantum electrodynamic vacuum
breakdown
so you
what you could actually do
imagine
a rip in the space-time continuum so
basically whatever you you
generate this
energy density with would be sucked
for lack of a better word into this uh
conditioned vacuum it's no longer your
regular quantum it's like a void within
the vacuum
okay and then what are the implications
of that what happens after that
a lot of it's quite possible that
a very anomalous physical phenomena for
example new methods of transport
you never have
this idea your regular propulsion ideas
you no longer have to implement for
example newton's third law it they would
they would move more these craft would
move more like
these uaps than they
in the schwinger effect there's also as
soon as the shrinker effect comes into
effect and by the way it's not been
shown because no one's been able to
generate this this is theoretical or
hypothetical it also causes a decay of
the electric field itself so does that
mean you have to continually supply an
electric field
yes
absolutely it's while the device is
operational that this
once the device stops you go back to
your regular quantum vacuum and your
back
again
nobody has generated this 10 to the 33
watts per meter square
i believe the bias effect can be used to
generate that using plasmas
exactly how i cannot say on this podcast
but i believe that is possible so yes
okay
i just use electrically charged solids
because it is easier to explain and
you're right it is not easy to obtain a
one coulomb electrical charge this is
extremely hot
we're getting some of the preliminaries
out of the way so how about we talk
about what the gertson's gene effect is
because that will come up plenty
sure sir
uh think of the gertzenstein the the
best way of thinking of it it's it's a
way to generate high frequency
gravitational wave
i believe the original paper was in the
was somewhere in
the soviet union in 1960
it um
and what he does is he uses nested
electromagnetic fields to generate high
frequency gravitational waves okay what
is the nested electromagnetic field an
electromagnetic field confined within
another
and the way i use it i basically
generate the pius effect
both within the interior the internal
electrolyte at the internal electro
electromagnetic field and the outer
electromagnetic field you can refer to
my uh
patent actually was you and this is very
interesting
uh
the craft using an inertial um
mass reduction device it took a great
deal of doing it a lot of work to get it
through
examination
the high frequency gravitational wave
generator was a first office
allowance which is amazing
for uh
such a
highly advanced
and highly controversial uh
subject matter but okay the gertzenstein
effect
theoretically can be used to generate
high frequency gravitational waves if
you can generate high frequency
gravitational waves again
what do you do you can alter the
space-time continuum in proximity of
your craft
so
it would move like these uaps move
for lack of a better analogy
so do you feel like these uaps are
operating under this principle
i am not
certain
uh
but it is quite feasible
yes it's peaceful i'll restate what the
gerchenstein or gristenstein effect is
if you have a strong magnetic field and
you pass an electromagnetic field
through that b field then you can
generate it's like a conversion you can
change from em waves to gravitational
waves now gravitational waves weigel has
only found them from black holes merging
low frequency remember
these are high frequency gravitation so
is ligo or is anyone else looking for
high frequency gravitational waves
because a question that pops into my
mind is if these craft are operating by
that principle then we should be able to
observe high frequency waves on the we
should be able to observe it with ligo
or some other experimental setup
that is a very good point i believe a
ligo cannot defe cannot detect high
frequency gravitational waves
if someone can show that is erroneous i
stand corrected but as far as i know
they detect low frequency gravitational
waves
so it is quite possible that ligo would
not uh pick up these uh
hypothetical
craft yeah okay we're gonna get into a
bit of the details here so on screen you
can't see this but i'll place this into
the
podcast once it's edited but
perhaps i could show you here the image
that i'll be showing is
is is that
oh yes that's the uh craft using the
inertial mass reduction device right
okay so let's go through this these
microwave emitters what are they doing
what they use for is to generate high
frequency vibration of the
plasma
remember there's like a xenon plasma and
that affects the outer
outer wall so it ro it it actually it
starts resonating it at very high
frequencies remember that outer wall is
electrically charged
and
it would have to be because uh
though the way the pius effect is
formulated
so um yeah go ahead forgive me if i
retread the same ground repeatedly it's
just how i'm understanding it i want to
make sure that i'm not misunderstanding
anything
okay so
we have this craft here
and
there is plasma where
sort of the plasma is
see where these waves are this is like a
it's like a fluorescent how there's a
fluorescent tube and it's hollow and
that's filled with a plasma or will make
it into a plasma so it's that there's
some plasma inside the walls
of right
right okay so there's some plasma and
then the microwave emitters are there in
order to accelerate their vibrational
frequency
yes
you you need that in order to get these
high frequencies of vibration
now exactly exactly how you'd make sure
that the plasma does not contact the
walls that's i cannot talk on this
podcast
okay and over here it says it's
dielectric liner so can you explain what
that is a dielectric liner
it would make sure that the electrical
charge is it's basically a boundary for
the electrical charge the electrical
charge cannot pass that it's like an
insulator that's what the dielectric
boundary so yeah and these microwave
emitters once they're turned on after
some time i don't know how long then it
will
induce the swinger effect
it will induce the frequencies that you
need to achieve the uh
the schwinger effect with
remember the whole idea of the schwinger
effect is to
break down the quantum vacuum
which would mean to create
discontinuities in your space-time
so-called continuum
and once you achieve these so-called
voids within the vacuum then the craft
can be sucked into that area of
i believe uh dr david frohning or i'm
not sure whether yes dr frohning uh
spoke of it as a conditioned vacuum if
you refer to his work
david froning
i i think he goes by his middle name
somehow but his last name is froning
and he speaks of it as a conditioned
vacuum
whereby you can facilitate the movement
of
these
inertially reduced craft
i do believe his last name is frowning
it's i think it's spelled f-r-o-n-i-n-g
throning another effect that you should
go over is the pergogan effect if i'm
pronouncing that correctly oh the
brigogine effect yes the ilia prigogene
i believe 1977 nobel prize winner in
non-equilibrium thermodynamics
the idea that if you have a non-linear
medium which
could be a plasma again
if you inject uh electromagnetic energy
into it and then you ex you somehow
injected a source to drive the plasma
far from equilibrium
then
it is possible that these plasmas will
self-organize
thereby
giving rise to
what's called the primogene effect i'm
not quite sure if anybody refers to it
as the prigoshine effect but he talks of
it in his nobel prize lecture
uh i think it's called time structure
and fluctuations it was given um at
stockholm in in
1977 upon receipt of his nobel prize
in non-equilibrium thermodynamics you
can actually see
he talks about
this idea in the form of i believe he uh
talks about bernard cells uh bernard
cells it's a flu dynamic phenomena that
occurs when you have a
certain layer of oil over heated plate
and how eventually these uh
chaotic seemingly chaotic
cells eventually self-organizing these
these beautiful almost i think hexagonal
shapes
and hence the pregoshin effect and it
can again it can be applied to any
non-linear medium i i choose a plasma
because it it is a an incredible struct
it's an incredible state think of it
it's the fourth state of matter
and i believe it's quite possibly the
bridge
to
[Music]
let's call it quintessence for lack of a
better term yeah
what's meant by non-linear medium a
non-linear medium would be a medium in
which
your energy
is quite possible with resonate will be
amplified
if added
it will no longer be
incrementally
amplified it'll be non-linear let's see
so the effect would be parabolic for
example again the idea of instead of
omega omega square like you find in the
pisce effect so yeah that's what i mean
by an alien medium
okay so the non-linear medium is the
plasma and that's inside the resonant
cavity of this craft and that is
resonating because of the microwaves
yes sir yes okay because you and as you
add as you as you uh
accelerate in frequency of these
um
exactly how how these frequencies uh are
accelerated i cannot speak on the
podcast but it it is feasible to get
this omega square effect rather than
your regular linear omega
because again we're trying to
counterbalance this q squared term this
charge square term
because you know
again it's hard to get that one coulomb
of charges you have assume yourself as
have remarked so
but it is much
much better to get these high
frequencies
using either piezoelectrics or plasmas
under certain
structure now forgive me if i'm taking a
while to come up with questions it's
only because i'm going through my notes
and there's so much
actually
for most people i have them all on one
page but for you they're scattered
amongst
maybe six documents here yes
and either way i'm not i'm not terribly
concerned because i
we're going to be editing this and it'll
be pristine once it's finally put up so
for the few people who are watching
you're going to have to bear with my
ineptitude inhebitude
okay so let's see here and my diatribe
okay while i'm coming up with mainly a
clarificatory question do you have any
questions for do you have any comments
or clarifications
it it would be great if uh i know that
you have background in theoretical
physics could you for example because
eventually i want to talk about the
sorry idea of the super force the force
of unification could you go into the
idea of quantum gravity and and speak on
it because i know you're quite
knowledgeable in this area sure so how
about this will take about four and a
half minutes maybe five and a half
minutes or so it's just that i haven't
seen any explanation of why quantum
gravity is a particularly tough
formidable subject outside of it being
strewn across many lectures and
certainly never concise and even precise
in a podcast so if you don't mind i can
go through that oh please go ahead sir
and by the way why i say this is that
you've had a tremendous podcast with
professor carlo rovelli who are greatly
greatly holding great esteem just like i
hold professor stefan alexander very
much in greatest team i wish he had
responded to my emails on the super
force but
that's another matter
um carlo rovelli in his uh
he spoke of this new book i think it was
published in 22
by uh professor jacom he goes by jay
armas of the university of st
conversations on quantum possibly
that is exactly it sir
and uh if you can take it away please do
in classical gravity there are a couple
principles that are held as sacred you
have them as assumptions these
assumptions are motivated but they're
somewhat their assumptions so general
covariance that's a technical term you
can look this up locality and locality
what that means is that your lagrangian
at any point depends only on that point
and then the derivatives at that point
rather than this point and then some
point that's far away and then you also
have a third assumption which is that
you don't have a dependency on
derivatives of order three or greater
you also have
see some people say background
independence which sounds like we're
placing all space times on an equal
footing quote unquote but then this
whole equal footings business you hear
people say the space and time are on
equal footing i think that should go
away if they're myths that hold you back
they sound nice but space and time are
not put on equal footing in einstein's
equations because you have a minus sign
with the time direction so they're
similar footing but they're not the same
footing and then also background
independence placing all space times on
equal footing it doesn't make sense
because that would mean you'd have to
have a measure on all space times such
that you can say that they're all equal
in some way and it's not quite apparent
how to do that okay anyway one of the
problems with quantum gravity is getting
back to our known laws because you have
to cross many scales there's like 10 to
the 40 scales either the order of the
order is about correct and in condensed
matter physics if you you know what
space time is you know what it means for
an atom to be in a particular place
well when you're describing the
fundamentals of space time itself what
does it mean to be at a particular place
what does an observable mean an
observation is generally at a particular
time now even in classical gr an
observation at a particular time isn't
well defined so then one of the reasons
why people go into 3d gravity you'll
hear this term plenty
is because in 3d gravity in gravity in
general whenever you're trying to
quantize it you
study vacuum equations which means you
remove all the matter and in 3d gravity
it turns out that the richie tensor is
zero and then that means that the
riemann tensor is zero which means that
it's locally flat which means that it's
a topological field theory and what that
means is that it's extremely well
behaved and it's nice to study you can
deform space time and correlation
functions aren't affected
okay now how do we go about quantizing
gravity so here's one way and this is
the approach of loop quantum gravity
it's that you remove all the matter
because you generally want to study
vacuum equations and then you take a
surface
and then you set that surface at t
equals zero and then that surface has to
be a cauchy surface so there's so many
technical requirements here and a koshy
surface is a it's not kosher although
it's kosher to be
koshi
it's a technical requirement to be koshi
then you make a manifold into a poisson
manifold okay so how do you do that well
you place a poisson algebra now the
reason why i'm saying all of this it's
so baroque and esoteric most people
their eyes are glazing over it's because
firstly many people are somewhat lied to
by these people who are popularizers of
science by them speaking down to the
audience and simplifying overly
simplifying it and i feel like for 30
years the public has been mystified by
wave particle duality and that needs to
needs to go away
yeah wave particle duality is it's not
that something is a wave and a particle
it's a quantum mechanical object and
it's something different well anyway so
i'm speaking with these intricate terms
so that people who are interested can
then look it up by the way this is
called canonical qg but it's a
non-canonical choice of a because you
chose a slice and now you understand it
okay what is a plus on algebra plus an
algebra is a lea algebra that's
associated with the derivation okay now
you understand it classically now
classically you have q and p which are
like phase space and that's understood
as a member of a cotangent bundle over
the space of positions
so then what you want is a hilbert space
that has the same commutation relations
but with operators on hilbert space so
then for qg you think
okay how about instead of a cotangent
bundle over r3 which is classical
mechanics you take a cotangent bundle
over the space of solutions of
einstein's equations but then this is an
infinite dimensional space and it has
singularities and it's not even a
manifold it's an orbit fold and then
it's not even a cotangent bundle for
technical reasons then you wonder the
technical reasons have to do about
constraints and then constraints play a
role because i know this gets a bit
baroque but i'm almost at the point
technical constraints there's a tricky
role with them because let's say you
have r2 and then let's say you want a
particle to be restricted to the y-axis
on r2 well what you can do is you can
set x equal to zero sure okay but then
what do you do with the momentum do you
set momentum equal to zero it turns out
that you shouldn't do it like that what
you have to do is you have to mod out by
px is equivalent to px plus a constant
and that's called a poisson reduction
and so there are many different small
but extremely technical reasons why one
can't simply make a superficial
quantizing of gravity and then you also
have to mod out by phase space except
phase base in this space
in this case is a diffiomorphism group
and then it's that's strange because in
traditional physics you act on a system
with time with time translation but you
don't mod out by time and then in the
canonical approach it's not easy to
define what it means to be a square
integrable space over all romanian
metrics on three manifolds so you have
square integrable spaces in hilbert
spaces in traditional quantum mechanics
so instead you define a new variable
where the metric is in the variable and
that variable is an su
connection called a spin connection
and so then a spin network and then you
get to spin networks from here so spin
network is a graph where each
edge is an irreducible representation of
some group and then each vertices
assigned to it an intertwiner which
relates them and so on but you can see
what's you can see that
all of this is extremely technical and
that
it's not that one doesn't understand
quantum gravity because they're missing
consciousness for example or someone who
believes they've watched enough neil
degrasse tyson and three blue one brown
that they can solve quantum gravity and
the yang mills mask happens etc there
are technical reasons why quantum
gravity doesn't work and if one could
solve it it would be worthy of a field
medal in and of itself okay so that's
quite a slew of information that i may
end up cutting from the podcast but
we'll see i'll trim that down
so that's
quantum gravity
i hope you do not cut any of it sir
dr eric einstein and sir raja penrose
would be extremely proud of what you
just said
more people should explain quantum
gravity this way not just
yeah anyway
the way it's done well look the the
space time is classical and smooth and
quantum gravity is fluctuates and so you
have to it's not as simple as that i
mean
well it's not as simple as that anyway
no now that i've talked about quantum
gravity for a bit too long why don't you
talk about what the super force is and
how you believe that solves some of the
problems in quantum gravity
okay
it's interesting because you can say
this would go back to sir isaac newton
uh i think it was
1693
i could be possibly wrong with you he
writes a letter to his friend in which
he says what if
what if gravity is caused by an agent
capital a
that acts
constantly
in accordance with given laws of nature
why
what if this agent capital a
is the super force and what i mean by
the super force would be like the force
of unification the force would that
would rule over the other forces
and
equalize
all forces
i believe it does exist
at the plank scale now why at the planck
scale
look carefully at the structure of
general relativity formalism that's used
by einstein and i shall not use richie
or
remaining curvature formalism i'll use
einstein tensor so g sub mu nu
equals what a 8
pi
big g divided by c to the fourth
the whole thing times t sub mu nu that t
sum you knew again representative energy
density
but look carefully at that scalar
constant
it has a term in it c to the fourth
divided by big g
well if you do the math
that term comes from a in blank energy
divided
by planck length
so
your plank mass times c square the whole
thing divided by g h bar divided by c
cube
the whole thing one half
the thing comes up with c to the fourth
divided by g
how can you get a planck force
featuring within
general relativity and it goes further
you can find the c to the fourth divided
by big g
what's
i term the super force
this force of unification in the dirac
equation which is the relativistic form
of schrodinger equation the foundational
form formalism of quantum mechanics
which is absolutely remarkable that the
c to the fourth divided by g should
figure not only that but the super force
equals the planck force
and the blank force does not have hbar
in it so it's non-blankian in nature
it's classical which means
the super force which equals the blank
force at the blank scale
is the bridge
between the world of the very large
namely general relativity
and the world of the very small
represented by quantum field theory and
according to
professor j armas this is what's needed
a force of unification a bridge
that would unify all four known forces
in this case including gravity even
though some people think of it as
non-force they think of it as a
space-time geometric
curvature but if you look carefully okay
and now that i've said what i've said
with the c4
c to the fourth divided by big g
look carefully at einstein equation it
can be reformulated
it actually saying
that the super force
acting on the space-time geometric
structure
gives rise to energy density hence
matter
and you can just see by rearranging the
terms of the equation that that's
exactly what's saying not only that if
you look carefully at the bekenstein
hawking formulation for entropy of a
black hole
c to the fourth divided by big g also
features in that
because your entropy of a black hole
would be given as h bar
divide or actually
k sub b which is the boltzmann constant
divided by h bar c
that term times c to the fourth divided
by g
times your area of the black hole
that would be your entropy
and you can actually see that i'm
correct the actual and the significant
again is that it is the super force
acting on the area of the black hole
that generates this black hole entropy
hence i believe it's the super force
that's the bridge the c to the fourth
divided by big g
which is non-plankin in nature acts as
the bridge between the world of the very
large and the world of the very small
and it is it exists at the planck scale
at every point in space and time
okay so help me understand what does it
mean when you say that it acts on it so
firstly let me make this clear when you
say super force you're referring to the
planck force
and people can look at what the plank
forces yes okay yes and then secondly
when you say it acts on it so let's
imagine we have
g
equals k times t
and forget about g is
einstein forget i'm just making up some
variables actually i could have said x
equals k times y
i wouldn't say
k is acting on y
but you're saying k is acting on y in
that case so what does that mean to me i
see that as a proportionality constant
so that's like a conversion factor
okay so think of the analogy between the
main formula of general relativity g sub
mu nu equal that scalar constant times d
sub mu nu now
transform it into
dimensional
character just think of it
would be 1 divided by l square where
your l would be some characteristic
length could be the planck length equal
um l divided by e
times e divided by l cubed what's your
energy okay right
right e divided by l cube that's your
energy density term well
what is a force it's a it's really the
gradient of an in of an energy that's
why that e divided by l is really your
super force and if you
just
put that term on the other side it's
actually saying it's the super force
acting on your space-time geometric
curvature that yields your energy
density hence matter so i believe it is
the super force that generates matter
based on whatever that space-time
geometric curvature local
in that particular domain is
so you could actually have a different
idea of what
it's just remarkable what einstein has
come up with it's it's
if you just restructure it you see a
whole different meaning of this formula
but still
and it says it is the super force
acting on the space-time geometric
structure that gives rise to energy
density hence matter
that is interesting i think
it's new anyway
it's just a new way of looking it's just
a new
perspective on old physics
okay so let me state it in my words and
see if this aligns with what you're
saying yes sir okay so traditionally in
einstein's equations you have g which
which colloquially is space time and so
geometry and then on the right side
there's t which is the stress energy
tensor which is thought of as the matter
now these are coupled but you can think
of it as
geometry and then there's some
proportionality constant in the matter
now you're saying that it's eight pi
divided by the plank four so let's just
move the plank force to this side so
plank force times the geometry equals 8
pi times the
matter distribution you can think of the
super force or the planck force in this
case
what is the super force it is the planck
force because it acts at the planck
scale so therefore the super force
equals the blank force so
what that equation now says it's the
super force that's acting on the
space-time geometric structure that
yields your t sum you knew your energy
density which represents matter
okay i'm going to need to think about
that some more because i still don't see
so the way that i see it is that okay
cool these numbers come up in a couple
different places it comes up in
quantum mechanics and it comes up in
relativity and these are what we're
trying to merge keep in mind c to the
fourth divided by big g why should it
come up in the dirac equation by a
manipulation of the terms
in the dirac equation or the schrodinger
equation and also in general relativity
and just think of it actually even
easier than that
if
this force c to the fourth divided by
big g
why should it be non-planking in a
classical realm
because it is planck energy divided by
uh planck length that all of a sudden
loses its hbar term so it becomes
classical why because the super force
must exist and it's 10 to the 44th
newtons
i believe it actually ah it acts at what
um
eventually we're going to talk about the
ashtakar bounce point
and you can give more in your podcast
you understand this because you read the
right yeah so astrocarb's bounce what
what sal is referring to is this paper
called the robustness of key features of
quantum of loop quantum cosmology so
people can look that up that will be in
the description
okay now you're saying this bounce is
relevant to your work because
because i'm saying it's the super force
that acts at the planck scales that at
this bounce point this ashtakar bounce
point
that actually you can think of it as
saying thus far and no further by
actually saying there are no space-time
singularities
it doesn't go to zero
it goes to the splanc scale
it's exactly what professor ashtakar
talks about when he talks about his
bounds
i believe it is the super force that
acts at this bounce that prevents
any so-called space-time singularities
from forming
this i still need to think about some
more so i'm going to be thinking about
it between now when we speak again
sure sir
and please make sure that you read that
conversation
i believe it's number three by the way
three uh
i like the number three very much so go
ahead
okay so just what sal is referring to is
there's this book called conversations
on quantum gravity which anyone who's
interested in quantum gravity should
read and there are different chapters
and each chapter is a theoretical
physicist talking about the problem of
quantum gravity from their point of view
which generally contradicts everyone
else's point of view so it's fun to
watch because they
pretty much are squabbling without
speaking to one another
number three is ashtakar
yes
did ball lightning inform your work with
plasma
i cannot say it did again what informed
it it was was the but that's a very good
question what informed it was this um
idea of
considering the heaviside version of of
maxwell's equation and this idea of that
you can get these extremely high
electromagnetic energy fluxes
but if you look carefully at this
question it's quite possible that that's
why it works that's why for example
it's a very unusual that these uh
these effects
these balls of plasma can actually go
through solid walls
you have to question why
how
you hear people talk about orbs in the
ufo circles do you believe these to be
related to ball lightning or some form
of plasma
i
quite believe that there are forms of
plasma yes soon it speaks it speaks to
this idea of quantum electrodynamic
vacuum by breakdown because once you
achieve these effects
all these anomalies can be present yes i
do believe that's possible
just to get a bit speculative here these
balls are usually of the size of the
order of a tennis ball to a basketball
they're generally not larger than a
building let's say so let's speak on the
ones that are small do you imagine that
to be a small craft a probe
hyper speculation again this is
okay the from a hyper speculation point
of view i would say it's quite possible
these are probes
yes
when
someone is operating in that craft that
you outlined in this
hybrid craft using an inertial maths
hybrid craft using an inertial mass
modification
device
article are you able to control the
craft from within it because in some of
these space-time engineer i know you're
not engineering the metric but in some
of these craft which depend on
space-time metric engineering it's not
as if you can control
the mechanism that propels you forward
so that you can stop it and move it left
and right and so on because it's
causally disconnected from you can you
control it in your model
i believe it's possible again refer to
froning's work and the conditioned
vacuum
once you can achieve these voids within
the vacuum it's quite possible that you
can
affect these uh
think of the craft as being sucked
within these voids within the vacuum
that i created
that's what frowning work talks to
and you can see his work you can i i
believe that
there are pdfs of it still available on
uh
if you google them
yeah
dr lachno or i don't know how to
pronounce it but doctor oh
victor lachno yeah
dr lacknow said or at least seem to be
one of the few that spoke positively
about your work in academia okay can you
speak about what his thoughts were
he believes that i am able to generate
uh
bose-einstein condensate-like states
whereby it is possible for these uh
room temperature high temperature
superconductive effects to be
achieved
uh i believe dr lachno again
he i'm not sure he could be of ukrainian
origin but i'm not sure
let's explain what a bose einstein
condensate is and then as well as what a
superconductor is
uh
what's the difference between the two
okay um
i wouldn't call myself uh a good
explanation i i could not provide a good
explanation of
of exactly what a bose-einstein
condensate is or all i could say is that
in a superconductor you can achieve
cooper pairing so you can so you can
actually have your electrons uh somehow
couple with one another so now they
actually
can move
smoothly
through your conductor
rather than uh
now exactly how this is done
because after all between two electrons
you have
a repulsion force a very high repulsion
force so exactly how this is done within
a superconductor
this is uh the idea of bcs theory i
think bardeen coupe and schrieffer they
also got the nobel prize for uh height
for uh
so for superconductivity i believe
but
it was not um
high temperature superconductivity now
professor lachno says it is possible to
generate these bose-einstein condensate
i i believe these are states of matter
when you go very extremely low in
temperatures
you you can actually have a coupling
between your electrons for example the
this whole idea of of cooper pairing how
these electrons couple to one another so
they actually move as one
uh i believe uh uh what the wolfgang
kettley professor cateley who's uh who
received a nobel prize for
uh the practical achievement of a
bose-einstein condensate
the best way to refer to it is to have
these electrons move as if they march in
lock step or one giant matter wave
here
called it
yes i have great respect for professor
catalay remarkable man he actually
answered one of my emails one time when
i was trying to publish
something it's extremely hard to publish
an archive every one of my papers
was rejected at archive
this is cornell university's uh
depository they usually uh
publish there before they go on to try
to publish an uh prestigious journey
uh
the first time that i tried to publish
they had no idea who i was and when i
sent them
i think one or two of my
uh previously published papers also uh
that i have a doctorate and mechanical
and aerospace engineer from case western
reserve university in cleveland ohio
when i send this to them they basically
said so what is this so what uh you know
uh we we need you
no not at all uh we need you to get uh
some some sort of sponsor so that's when
i started writing to notable physicists
that
i assumed you know could could possibly
sponsor the work one of them was
professor cately another one was
professor maldasena of the advanced
institute
at princeton um
unfortunately neither would sponsor the
work so i just gave up and went with the
baton rouge
so you don't just have one patent you
have three and you had trouble with only
one is that correct and the other two
were fine
actually there were five patent
applications put in there was a high
energy electromagnetic field generator
it received the pattern there was the
craft using an inertial mass reduction
device that received the pattern after a
lot of going back and forth with the
primary examiner mr phillip bonzell
a great great man by the way very very
very technically up
uh he posed some very
key questions that
like for example fortunate enough
again he said how can you produce i mean
neutron stars for goodness sake again
can you know and electric fields on the
order of 10 to the 18 volts per meter
you're talking about the schwinger limit
and commensurate with b fields on the
order of 10 to the nine tesla again that
equals cb
relationship um
so
he really knew his stuff and we were
able against uh
one of the things that i sent you uh uh
did that uh primary examiner interview
uh that um there are series of slides
that aided to his acceptance of uh
of uh
that pattern the allowance of that
pattern here we had a very strong appeal
that was based partially on that phone
interview and the where the slide
presentation was presented and that got
us through on that one now another one
was the high frequency gravitational
wave generator
that pattern application also received
that was the first office allowance that
went through extremely smoothly
which for the controversial subject
matter discussed was very interesting
and uh then there were two more there
are room temperature
superconductor uh which we actually
changed the name to high temperature
superconductor thinking maybe that
would make the primary examiner more
more malleable it did it
and so that pattern application and the
last one a plasma compression fusion
device which was i was fortunate enough
to actually publish in ieee
transaction on plasma science a very
prestigious journal
uh of plasma physics
especially uh which deals with nuclear
fusion
actual
production of nuclear fusion and um
the chief editor of of the found it very
refr very refreshing i still remember
one of the comments
again it's it's
these are new ideas they're quite
some people call them revolutionary some
people call them breakthrough
any which way these are new perspectives
on old physics i would not call these
new physics at all right because they're
based on all physics it's just a new
interpretation for example the whole
idea of the super force how the super
force can the rise in einstein classical
relativity for
formalism even though
the super force is really blank energy
divided by plank length
meaning it is the blank force so it acts
at the blank scale
again just new ways of looking at all
physics that's all this is
can you remind me once more what the
electric field strength is
the schwinger limit is 10 to the 18
volts per meter okay so look if i do
this little calculation just the back of
the envelope well right back at the wall
from alpha envelope here it says that if
you are 10 000 kilometers away from
something that generates that you should
feel 10 to the 10 what is the unit again
giga volts or what what is it
oh i'm not i'm not an engineer
i don't deal with numbers
10 to the 18 volts per meter
that's your schwinger voltage yeah
look let's say it's 10 to the 18 and
then you divide by r squared and then
you just say well look can i feel if
something at some part of the planet is
generating this swinger effect i should
be able to feel it at some other part of
the plant drastically so firstly is that
correct
i would not know i've never generated
those kind of energy densities i would i
would not know
just based on falloff by r squared
my opinion is that it generates this in
the proxy it's a local effect so it
generates it in proximity of the craft
so it does not
it doesn't bleed out somehow
yes exactly it's it it becomes um it's
as if it's a break it's a break in the
space-time continuum it's as if again
you generated a void
within the quantum vacuum there's
absolutely nothing
at that
point
you know how there's like lost in
criterion for the super conductors yes
is there something else that talks about
how damp it would be like how far it
would have to be before it starts to
fade off rapidly even greater than r
squared
i have absolutely no clue i i've done no
further work on this than i have already
done and as far as i know nobody's
picked up on it because everybody thinks
again these are the ideas of a crackpot
and some people have called me what a
charlatan a crank
i've been called many names how does
that make you feel
it's hard i will tell you the truth
because i i i used again all physics and
just
regular
dimensional analysis actually over
rather simplistic nature to generate
these formalisms
and
why would people
you know
why why must they denigrate other
individuals
with such i would never do it
absolutely not i i would try for example
to see whether it's experimentally
feasible
but
on and and even and even if that person
is proven false i would definitely not
use such such uh such term some
i i do not understand why that makes
certain people feel better to use such
injurious language because it is an
injury
i'm sorry man i i've spent many
sleepless nights just reading i've
stopped reading everything that was
written on my work
because i can't take it anymore i'll
tell you the truth
it's just
it's it's hurtful there's no need for it
to stand up for you as to the degree
that i can
from what i've read at least much of it
not all of it but much of it is like you
mentioned like old physics and you're
just plugging in certain numbers and so
to me the main critique shouldn't be
that this is the work of a crackpot but
for me the main critique would be how
does one know that this is even
achievable that there's not some other
mechanism that comes into play that
stops it so for example just because one
can write down a space-time metric like
the schwarzschild metric it doesn't mean
that first the schwarzschild metric is
not physically realizable in the sense
that it's sure it's a black hole but it
has time symmetry so it doesn't describe
a collapse and it also has zero charge
like is that realistic and so on so just
because i can write a solution same in
newtonian mechanics too by the way most
all of newtonian mechanics is idealized
but i'm referring to something as simple
as let's put a certain amount of mass
such that light can no longer escape
like who knows if some other physical
law comes into play before that point
turns out it does it's gr but that would
be my critique would be like my critique
would be
well who knows if some other mechanism
comes into play to stop these numbers
from reaching
the
the amounts that you say rather than
this is the work of a of an insensate
crank who is just trying to bolster his
ego and his reputation by claiming to
invent a flurry of new products each of
which would be worthy of their own nobel
prize on their own so at least that
would be my critique and i don't like
the denigration that's put forward to
you or to anyone else and i hope that
this podcast can serve to show people
that you're not someone who doesn't know
what they're talking about
i thank you sir and i salute you for
that
you are one of the few physicists who
have said
some nice words some practical words
you're right this must now be the realm
of experiment and careful
experimentation of certain of these
ideas should be made to see whether this
effect does occur or not
rather than
use slur and language that's
not needed
now speaking of experimental tests is it
possible that if someone was to fund you
how much money would it take and how
much time would it take for you to
produce the effects
experimentally physically it's
physically realizable
sir the truth of the matter is uh
my work uh now that i i cannot speak off
i work for the
for the federal government i um
has nothing to do with this work
and
whether
it would have to be the federal
government and some agency that i i
would never perform such work for a
private individual i i
i apologize for this greatly but i think
they're matters of national securities
that must be respected and
if i'm anything at all call me a crown
call me a charlotte and call me a
crackpot but sir i am a patriot
and it stops at that
that's all
i'm not sure i'm not sure of the numbers
involved i'll tell you the truth i'm i'm
far more i'm i'm more of an any an
engineer of
i'd love to call myself a physicist even
though i cannot i do not have the
correct pedigree
even though i've dabbled
um in um
i'm not an administrator i'm more of a a
technical guy and i'd rather stay that
way so i would need a whole team i most
likely it would involve some budget
people who come up with the but
this would be
in the realm of a multi-million dollar
effort this is not something that you
would do with half a million in three
years
see something i'm thinking about is if
these were indeed operable which you're
not saying they are and if the navy or
the us government did indeed believe in
them
then they could easily file it under a
secrecy act they didn't have to make it
public
so do you feel like you're so firstly
why did they make it public and is part
of the reason because it's a preemptive
strike against the possibility of it
being one day developed by a competitor
i think
my opinion uh just look at rose cole
hart's
book name in plain sight sometimes the
best way to hide something is in plain
sight
what does that mean
i'm remember i'm just a lowly
podcaster
a failed filmmaker so explain what that
means please
it's quite possible that no one knows
exactly
the end effect of all this work
and therefore why
why classify it why
and and even if it was correct and it
could lead to all these breakthroughs
sometimes the best way to hide something
is in plain sight
because again
who would
do you see any mainstream physicists
trying to take on the bias effect and
trying to prove its validity absolutely
not they would rather call me a crank
and crackpot and shout and rather than
try to do the experiments and see
whether they work or not
so it's much easier to call it a work of
disinformation
and leave it at that
my biggest fear is that
certain
nefarious elements would pick up on this
work and
find validity within it
and that's why
language was made
specifically in those patent
applications to deter any such
nefarious elements from proceeding
on some of these ideas
let's just leave it at that i cannot
substantiate what that means
your viewers are very intelligent so i
know they will pick up on certain things
okay i'm not terribly intelligent so
let's so let me ask you a question and
then you can choose to answer or not the
way that you describe quantum gravity
sir speaks against that volumes
what i'm thinking is see i'm going
through it and i'm trying at least
arduously to take it seriously
and to wrestle with it and go through
the details and i personally didn't see
anything in there that would say to a
country who doesn't have our interests
at hand who knows even if our own
government has our own interests and who
knows but
you understand what i'm referring to i
didn't see anything in there that would
stop them from doing the same
investigation that i'm doing so what are
you what are you referring to what do
you mean can you talk around it
i left out some of the secret sauce
okay now what do you make once people
say well there has to be disinformation
in it not just incomplete information
dis information
i did not write these patent
applications and i'm pretty sure the
government did not file them in order to
create
false information
these were
written to the physics of the effects
that i was following through
that's all
they were not meant to
scare off anybody
they're a new window into new
opportunities and
it's quite possible again these have
such commercial
possibilities
they don't need to be weaponized
if indeed the bias effect
or the schwinger effect or whatever i
want to call it
if indeed this effect is valid
it could lead to new
to a new world
why not
give it that opportunity
that's
all
and i really wanted the navy to have
these because if if any of the
contractors if any of the uh
companies that
form the military-industrial complex
if if any of them have or
will come up with these ideas
they will charge navy great amounts of
money
to to make them feasible if the navy
already has them
those prices can be talked down
be alleviated and
that's why i actually accepted no
royalties for this whatsoever none
not one cent
i did it out of pure patriotic duty
and i stand by those words
that's all
maybe that's why it hurts so much when
i'm gonna crack
i can imagine
yeah
how does your family handle that
they stay away from it that they they
they don't get involved every now and
then
my daughter will show me
hey look daddy that this particular
person thinks you're okay
um
and puts a smile on my face you know
yeah that's that's a good she tries not
to show the negative things and i'm
still well that's good that's good i've
stopped
yeah it's just unbelievable so yeah just
leave it there
once this finally goes online please
have your daughter filter out some of
the comments to show you
okay please don't read them because i'm
sure this there's a quite well you can
imagine
i can understand
that's okay
everyone is entitled to their opinion
so
but i would never call those individuals
these kind of words
again
there's no need to be hurtful
we can be quite
actually
great steps in in
advances in physics can be done
with people that cooperate
rather than
be offensive to one another there's no
need for hurtful words period i'll leave
it at that right
so you mentioned eric davis
eric w davis yes sir
dr eric w davis what are his comments on
your work
from what i know they're not
congratu
they're not
positive that's it so yeah
why do you think that is do you think
because obviously he's an extremely
intelligent person extremely and if he
believed that this was i'm getting a bit
tired so forgive me if i as i that's
quite all right sir i'm i'm i'm getting
there too i this this is heavy physics i
tell you so yeah definitely i mean he is
in a position to judge
the veracity of this
yes so i would imagine that he would be
able to see whether it's true or not so
what do you make of him and his
dis-logistic comments
i would just say tried experimentally
from what i know
his associate dr harold putov has
better things to say about my work i'll
just leave it at that because there's
nothing official on that and that's hold
on sal if you can hear me i can't see
you right now hold on oh boy sorry so
you're saying from what i know his
associate sorry continue that right from
what i know his associate dr harold put
off has uh better
better ideas of my work and
but that's of a private nature so i
cannot go into that
the best thing to do is actually go to
dr davis uh directly and ask him why
why does he think my work is not
worth the paper that's written
i would like to speak to dr eric davis i
spoke to him briefly over email just had
a couple email exchanges but nothing
substantial i'd also like to speak to
jax or fatty who also has his own ideas
as to how these tic tacs work
unfortunately dr safari also does
nothing highly
well it seems like each person is
uncomplimentary to the
other actually i think both of their
works are very interesting i wouldn't i
i think there's value in them both and
they should all be given
finances to follow
their theories
so from my perspective i think they're
worthwhile
it's interesting how both of them think
mine is not it's uh
it hurts i'll tell you the truth i can
see that man and that alone puts you in
a great category that even though you're
being criticized that you're not willing
to criticize them or at least you know
the criticisms will will be laid
strictly at the work itself rather than
the person and that you still say that
hey even if i don't think this will work
they should be allowed to explore it and
perhaps it should even be funded to
explore it
i would never say something i don't
think that would work i think experiment
is essential improving whether
a physical theory is correct or not
and if anything fails experiment
then we should look not necessarily
abolish the theory just give up on the
theory but see whether there's something
we've missed
within the theory to make it
experimentally verifiable
it's too easy to give up on things that
i
again
i think a lot of physicists have given
up on philosophy which which
is essential i think physics without
philosophy is like a seed without water
fruitless
it's important for physicists to also be
philosophers and i've always tried to
to have that this is why i love the work
of professor carlo robelli i think
professor carl rovelli is
also a great philosopher and there is
absolutely no stigma attached to that i
think
all great physicists at one point in
time were great philosophers look at sir
isaac newton look at
so roger bacon look at uh
um
why not
yes look for example francis bacon
francis bacon i'm i i i apologize so
roger penrose is what you're thinking of
and then you combine that with yes i
understand
he also has a philosophy yes things so
roger penrose is amazing
it's a dr eric weinstein his uh
he he had a
an interview i'm not sure whether it's a
recent maybe a one-year-old interview
with saraja penrose before sarajev
once about two years ago yeah right on
on the portal i believe it was very
interesting
and and you can see the admiration and
serve raja penrose eyes
of dr y again dr weinstein his idea of
joy of geometric unity
why
must people say nay
give it a chance man i mean
this is what physics should be all about
i can't think of any other reason
other than
jealousy
i don't know
i i
i've never thought badly of anybody
else's work so i i cannot put myself in
their shoes and judge well the reason i
say that is because i see that in myself
i see there's so much jealousy in myself
and there's so much criticism that i do
of other people in my own head luckily i
i temper it and i try to stay away from
it
but
i
i see that quality in myself and so
it's
something i can identify in others
mainly because i suffer from that
perhaps to in
on an order of magnitude much larger
than the other people that i'm
saying suffer from the same
sins
i don't see that in you sir at all as a
matter of fact
i
i admire you greatly and i admire the
work that you do and i hope series of
everything podcast stays on forever
because it's no you do a great service
to the community the guests that you've
had on are remarkable people with
remarkable ideas
i
i think if your podcast was ever to stop
i don't know what i would do in my free
time
i absolutely love it so
well that's just extremely kind of you
thank you so much
did you get to watch that podcast with
gross and
david gross and carlo rivelli
i have such admiration for both
gentlemen
very much so but
at one point in that interview when the
host
uh
calls um
professor rovelli uh
a poet
or something to do with philosophy
if you can see the expression on
professor gross's face
just i mean this is a nobel prize winner
one of the best physicists it was an
expression of what
distaste was not
it was more like of
something of the nature it was not
something that professor gross should be
associated with and i'm pretty sure that
he never meant to have that but for some
reason the host
had him you know had
again philosophy should have never been
divorced from physics
period
unfortunately that divide
has been created
and as a result i think we've lost a
great deal
in physics
again these new ideas these uh
everybody wants new physics
why not new perspectives on old physics
there's nothing wrong with all physics
just because those books start spelling
musky at times doesn't mean you should
put them away
that's one of the reasons i'm excited to
speak with jack cerfati and or his
collaborator keith wesner from
california state fullerton because at
least in jack's words it's not new
physics it's the same physics just with
it
just from another perspective well his
is from a meta materials perspective and
then using that to change what is that
proportionality factor that's right
beside the stress energy tensor
right
yes
what is your opinion on
why james sheehy
attested to
the
let me let me make sure i phrased this
correctly please
and i'm so glad that i'm just with you
here i'm i'm terribly not nervous which
i usually am extremely nervous
because you i feel so comfortable with
you
you you definitely should you're you're
one of the best people that i i i would
like to know on a personal level one day
that you you truly are remarkable okay
and i i hope your podcast brings you
great fame sir you deserve it
thank you i'm not sure i'm not looking
for fame but i know what you mean
success in some manner
yeah however you want it yes yes you
deserve it yes thank you thank you maybe
yeah okay thank you
if if people
okay no i'm not gonna do that let's okay
let's see here
hmm
uh yeah yeah it was essentially there
was nothing different than what i was
saying essentially so the cto of naval
aviation enterprises james sheehy
correct
he was at the time he no longer is
i have no idea sure why did he at the
time personally vouch for the patent
for its operability
maybe was the passion
that i actually showed him i actually
went to the blackboard in his office
that it took a great while to get to
that level
but
i was able to go from fundamentals to
show him that it is possible to get such
high energy densities again just from
the heavy side
some some people say heavyside gibbs
version of maxwell's equation let's just
say oliver heavyside's
uh
representation of maxwell's equations i
was able to convince dr sheehy that
these kind of energy densities
are feasible
and if they're feasible and how i was
able to show them then his statements
make
perfect
truth
he was not he was not speaking
badly or
he
he realized
the passion and these ideas and the
possibilities that they represented and
here's a great answer
if if you met him you would be
you'd truly be
in awe of this man he's he's a he's not
just a good man he's a great man
he's able to listen
and he's able to understand
what other people would
just
not even pay attention to immediately
they will say no impossible
rather than con consider the conditional
possibilities of these so-called
seemingly impossible feats
when earlier you were referring to
the patents you mentioned that they were
incomplete in some manner but as far as
i know from patent law they have to have
enough information in order for someone
to be able to reproduce it reasonably if
they had the technical know-how so
does that mean that technically
shouldn't have been patented
not at all sir there as far as the
the way they were enabled
it's perfectly fine
because remember that in
the whole idea of the piece effect
controlled motion of electrically
charged matter
from solids
to plasma states
subjected to accelerate vibration and or
accelerate spin via rapid acceleration
transients
now remember that
that's always been presented
of course the plasma state was never
discussed
that's where some of these
anomalies may occur just leave it at
that i cannot speak further on the
subject speaking of anomalies have you
ever encountered any ufos have you had
any any experience with quote-unquote d
phenomenon
not sir absolutely none sometimes i
i'm not sure whether actually i'm i'm
not sure i was about to say sometimes i
wish i had but now i'm not sure how i
would react maybe it would be tremendous
maybe i would lose control of my
faculties god forbid you know
no i feel i feel very
i mean this is such
oh
i know we're dealing here with the realm
of hyper speculation
sure but so many people have said that
they
observe these even when you look at some
of these cave paintings
showing objects
i mean
you don't need to have a doctrine in
physics to start questioning
where all these people's liars
where they're acting in concert because
many times their
explanation of these and again this
whole idea of this new uap office coming
into being
these are not mad man our our
this had congressional representation
it's a
strong stable people if they believe
there's something to this
am i to say there isn't
did you ever build on the research or
look at the research of ning lee or i
don't know how to pronounce this but
podky litanov's super conductors
evgeny potglernov
uh
he
is a very interesting i i read some of
his papers for example i read the one on
impulse generator
and the way that he used these
incredibly high voltages this discharge
i think he used a marks generator or
something of that nature to to provide
this impulse gravitational wave again
i
if you look at the pius effect they
never used any of those ideas this came
directly again from the heavy side
version of maxwell equation and i i
apologize for sounding repetitive but
that's exactly where it came from and
that's what convinced dr sheehy because
it came from fundamentals
things that he was accustomed to and
acquainted with
i was able to convince him
that's why he said what he said
let me forgive my rudimentary question
remember i'm not an engineer more on the
theoretical end if anything what's the
difference between a pulse and an
impulse
i myself would would
to me
and it sounds the same
almost maybe
an impulse could be the effect
of a pulsed action
one could be the effect of the other
possible
but sometimes i'll tell you the truth
language confuses me
maybe maybe because english is
not you know my first language what is
your personal romania
i was born in romania i came here when i
was 13 and a half years old and by the
way
uh
which means
long live the romanian people long live
romania
nothing without god
i'm uh i'm religious
always have been
but mostly since my mother passed away
from stage four liver cancer
and
it
you need something to i strengthen you
trust me i know i pray a whole lot
and
i never i would never
try to bring my beliefs to anyone else i
think
i think religion is a personal
i shouldn't be laughed at that
that's all
so you had a transition of work you went
from the naval air systems command to
naval strategic systems program and do
you like your new positions better
um
actually
i cannot say exactly where i work now
but i had moved on from the space
strategic systems programs uh the navy
uh to the space force
um
just new opportunities uh
new ideas to i'm an engineer so i like
to
do practical things
so when i'm presented with a new
opportunity sometimes
i pick up and go not necessarily with my
the the location of my uh uh abode
but with
just a new opportunity new faces new
ideas new
new possibilities
that's always intrigued me
maybe that's why uh this work spans
so many physics domains from condensed
metaphysics to general relativity to
quantum gravity and so forth
so yeah
i like to learn
i never stop learning
i think when you stop learning
something in you dies or it atrophies
you should always be
learning new things
now i'm
not necessarily saying
learn all things in all domains i
for example if i was to go into medical
field i
this is why i hold you in tremendous
esteem
for example the word the how you were
able to read on the work of dr carl
frist and this is
i do not think i could have read those
papers so my head down
i barely read them so
now
that's
even dr fristen at one point said
you know you you understand these
amazingly well so
congratulations
thank you i appreciate it you're too
kind man
now
sal has something happened behind the
scenes that allows you to come forward
like what is the reason for you coming
forward now rather than before and when
i say coming forward i mean at least
this is your first time on video there
was only i think two images of you
prior to this
so i'm in my mind i'm wondering is this
related to the nimitz and the disclosure
in general
not at all sir i just
the the book by rose coldheart um
again the chapter 23 in which he
basically say are these patents uh
merely a pathetic bluff to scare off
america's rivals
i would not have done
i would have i would have not performed
due diligence as an engineer and as a
as a person that serves
the american people and the federal
government i would have not done my due
diligence if i were to just
let it
just go by the wayside and say oh this
is
baloney because it is not a lot of work
went into these ideas a lot of work went
into these patent applications
and they're not meant to scare off
anyone they're meant to ask questions
and possibly
open new avenues towards
new ideas that's all
sal
thank you so much it's time for me to do
my due diligence and go through some of
that work in the super force because i i
still i'm unclear
and i need to
gain some clarity so perhaps i can send
you some emails and ask you what what
does this mean what does that mean for
our next conversation to be a bit more
illuminating when it comes to quantum
gravity and the super force relationship
to it
sure sir and please
if you see me now responding right away
is because i can basically just work on
this stuff during weekends you and i
have discussed this previously so okay
i don't want you to take it as an
upfront oh he's not
because it's no i know it's happened to
me when when people have let's say you
know i i write emails and nobody answers
for weeks and i i tell you it's not that
i do this because uh in any way it's an
affront to you it's
i i'm extremely busy at my work at this
point in time indeed leave it at that
yeah okay and also same with myself if
you don't get a response right away
sometimes you may not get a response for
about a week or two hey that's dude it's
dude to you okay
please don't don't forget uh hyperlink
to this because my wife was really
interested it said what what's going on
here yeah yeah so you know thank you
very much sir you're welcome i i cannot
help calling you sir because it's a term
of respect
and i call people my my boss at work sir
it's just a term of respect people i
respect i call sir
in in private conversations i'll call
you dude and brother and so forth but
it's different
i you are my brother
you and i
have a link our souls have a link
i like you very much on a personal level
just leave it at that all right
thank you sal thank you so i'm by the
way man when i say man like hey man so
that's my term of endearment okay i love
that i mean
i mean respect by that no no i had some
awesome friends
in new york city they oh my goodness oh
the language we used i could never use
that heirs
leave it at that yeah
okay all right so do you have any
message to say goodbye to the audience
because we're live and i'll either
include it or not depending on what you
want
sure uh
for everyone out there just cooperate
cooperate and try to be positive in your
thinking
give people the benefit of the doubt and
always experiment on new ideas and
remember it doesn't have to be new
physics
just new perspectives on all physics
there's nothing
wrong with all physics there's nothing
wrong with all
musky books that should never be thrown
in the fires they say
that's all thank you sir
my ending note is that there's a
misconception about physics that people
that these shifts are when people throw
out everything that had come before but
this isn't true it's mainly whenever
there's been well established theories
and there's inconsistencies then that's
an indication that specific changes are
needed to be made and revolutions aren't
from some place where someone found
themselves under a tree where they were
by a mayan temple and now they had this
insight and so it's completely radical
it's usually a conservative element and
a radical element you need both not just
conservatism because that's just the way
it's been and not just radical because
at least historically it's never been
that it's a combination of both so for
example einstein was extremely
conservative he had a certain set of
principles that he wanted to hold on to
tightly even when other people were
willing to throw out those principles so
he said no no this is what is
foundational and then from there he
built his theories
totally agree with her so and just one
more thing einstein's general relativity
formalism is absolutely
amazing
and everybody trying to prove einstein
wrong
think again
this man
he truly is you know every now and then
these forces of nature are born i
believe einstein was such a force
if enough satisfaction
okay
all right i'm gonna end the live stream
thank you everyone for showing up and
this will be edited and placed out in
about two to three days or so depending
on how much sleep i can get okay take
care everyone and sal stick around
because me and you will talk privately
it's absolutely sad right here
stop the live stream there we go okay so
now no one can see this let me make sure
about that just so that in case you want
to say anything private it's not i'm
saying end stream and there we go okay
great that's ending
okay
so
sal oh firstly
yes sir no not not firstly endly i will
make sure that i stop that audio
recording and then you can send me that
file
okay
well how how do i send it to you i'll do
i'll do it i'll do it for you okay yeah
you do it yeah yeah perfect okay so
let's think so how does that go for you
tremendous i mean you
you're
you're really good you're right on the
point and you um how should i say you
have some pertinent stuff some very good
practical questions so i hope i was able
to answer for example i got all screwy
on the boys the bose einstein kinda said
because i know the physics of it you
know i i know you want me to remove that
one part if you mess if you feel like
okay that's quite all right
let people know that i have deficiencies
i'm only a human being i make a lot of
mistakes i i certain things i do not
know but i remembered immediately
uh the work of dr volfran catalay and
was able to come back and basically
that's what it is it's when electrons
march forward and lock step that's
how you describe that a giant matter
wave that's exactly how dr cately
described it in his
nobel prize winning work i forget when i
think 2009 was that
uh the bullseye's not gonna i believe so
i
it it's it's funny the uh in in his
email to me because i i uh
of course i can i i wouldn't say i
complained but i said why are the
archived gatekeepers so hard on me you
know
said well you know otherwise they would
have to publish everything that was sent
to them you know and and uh he was right
in that
it's um
it's
and it wasn't condensed matter of
physics per se what i was sending so
that's why he you know he basically said
i
i'd rather not but i have a feeling if i
would have insisted he is that kind of
person he's a really nice guy
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you